- Well my motto, I was always
taught when I was young,
is nothing's going to get
handed to you on a plate.
So you have literally got to go out
and fight for everything you can get.
But it's out there.
(light music)
Me and my grand dad were trying to fix
a curtain rail to a plasterboard wall.
And it kept coming down, time after time.
So we went out to the local hardware store
and bought all the fixings
you could think of.
Nothing would work, so we literally,
he had a small, little garden shed,
so we went out in there
and mocked up something,
nothing like what it looks like today.
But it was basically the same
action, with a wing action
that spreads the load
behind the plasterboard.
And then we came back in,
tried it, and it worked.
And that was kind of
the, the moment, really.
But it was just to solve a problem.
When I was back at school,
when swine flu happened.
Everyone was going mad
about having to have
their hands clean and everything.
So I went into the local Asda,
and I think they were on sale for a pound,
so I bought everything they had in stock,
and then went to school and was selling it
for two, three pound, making a profit.
And I ended up getting
told off by the teachers,
so I stopped that.
And then I ended up
leaving school at just 13.
And I ended up starting
my own tutoring agency.
So it's kind of a personal
agency that found tutors
for people and put them
in touch with the clients.
I mean the time with GripIt,
we've grown so rapidly,
going on Dragon's Den was massive for us.
It gave us the money that we needed
to increase production,
and then we invented
a few more products since then.
A few new changes to the product,
and we've gone from 500
stores to 5,000 now.
So it's only a short
space, like two years,
so it's crazy.
Biggest challenge for me
is finding the right staff,
cause obviously, your business
is your baby sort of thing.
So now, trying to find the right staff
to put in the right place in the company
is my difficult challenge, trying to
hand that trust over sort of thing.
So what's next for GripIt is,
we're helping other inventors
that have done the same to us,
bringing their products to market,
so we're doing that through GripIt.
We're bringing out some
new products ourselves.
We've just gone over to
the U.S. and Australia,
gonna be a busy couple of years.
(inspirational music)